[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Bei mir dreht sich immer noch alles
rund um das Thema Einschulung.
Und weil ich so gerne
früher zur Schule gegangen bin...
Okay, jetzt fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich:
"Warum sieht sie heute so aus?
Warum sieht diese Frau heute so aus?"
Na ja, ich mache gerade parallel
eine Einschulungstorte im 90s-Stil
und deswegen habe ich mich
in meine 90s-Kleidung geschmissen.
Andere Geschichte.
Schaut euch einfach die Einschulungstorte an.
Deswegen sehe ich heute so aus.
Und weil ich ein Mädchen bin.
And girls just wanna have fun.
Fun!
Ja.
Heute gibt es Müsliriegel,
aber eigentlich keine Riegel, sondern kleine Müslisnacks.
Die könnt ihr euren Kindern mit zur Schule geben,
ihr könnt sie mit ins Büro nehmen,
als kleinen Snack einfach im Kühlschrank lagern
und morgens essen, wenn ihr Hunger habt,
oder einfach mal zwischendurch.
Diese Müsliriegel, die ich jetzt machen werde,
sind nämlich...
Also Bestandteile sind natürlich Haferflocken,
Amarant, getrocknete Früchte,
also alles, was dir wirklich auch so Energie gibt
und einfach mal auch schnell den Hunger stillt,
was aber auch viele Vitamine und Mineralstoffe enthält,
Ballaststoffe.
Und das Ganze eben to go,
also dass man es schön mitnehmen kann,
und ganz ohne Backen.
Also noch mehr Vorteile gibt es eigentlich nicht.
Ich zeige euch mal, welche Zutaten ich nehme.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch die eine oder andere Zutat austauschen,
ersetzen, wenn ihr was nicht dahabt.
Aber das ist so ein Grundrezept,
was ihr eben schön abwandeln könnt.
Ich verwende dafür
75 Gramm Mandeln,
80 Gramm getrocknete Aprikosen,
50 Gramm entsteinte Datteln,
20 Gramm getrocknete Äpfel,
50 Gramm Cranberries,
75 Gramm Haferflocken,
20 Gramm Amarant,
etwas Zitronensaft,
60 Gramm Orangensaft
und Backoblaten.
Das Einzige, was ihr jetzt beachten solltet,
ihr braucht einen Mixer oder Stabmixer.
Stabmixer wird schon ein bisschen schwierig.
Ihr braucht einfach was, um alle Zutaten zu zerkleinern.
Okay.
Ich mache das jetzt hier oben.
Aber es gibt ja auch so die Geräte ohne Strom,
zum Ziehen.
Kann man auch nehmen.
Man kann auch ein Messer nehmen und alles fein häckseln.
Aber es muss wirklich ganz, ganz fein sein.
Ich werde jetzt erst mal die Mandeln fein mahlen.
Schon zerkleinert.
Ich bin heute richtig
so richtig in 90s-Laune.
So richtig arg. Ja.
Die Aprikosen sind übrigens so dunkel,
weil das nicht geschwefelte Aprikosen sind.
Und wenn ihr diese ganz hellen, gelben Aprikosen habt,
die sind halt meist geschwefelt.
Auf die verzichte ich echt ganz gerne.
Und deswegen nehme ich einfach die dunklen.
Sind optisch nicht so schön,
aber das macht ja nichts.
Hauptsache, ich habe da nichts drin,
was ich nicht essen möchte.
Dann habe ich hier die Datteln,
– die sind bereits entkernt –
die Äpfel,
die Cranberries.
Da gucke ich auch immer,
dass ich Cranberries finde ohne Zucker.
Also die meisten sind halt echt mit Zuckerzusatz.
Aber es gibt ganz selten mal welche ohne.
Orangensaft mit rein ein bisschen zum Aufweichen.
Und Zitronensaft rein für den Vitamin-C-Kick.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
dass Cranberries auch schon viel Vitamin C enthalten.
Und ich habe ja auch viel Eisen mit drin
und Eisen kann einfach supergut aufgenommen werden,
wenn ihr Vitamin C mit dazu gebt.
Deswegen nehme ich für das Dressing für Salate
meist immer einen Schuss Zitrone mit rein.
Und jetzt schön vermixen.
Sieht super aus.
Jetzt gebe ich noch die Haferflocken mit rein.
Noch mal kurz mixen.
So. Jetzt gebe ich alles mal kurz in die Schüssel hier.
Ihr könnt es auch direkt aus der Schüssel weiterverarbeiten.
Aber ich möchte jetzt noch Amarant mit dazu geben.
So.
Dann gebe ich hier noch Amarant dazu.
Das ist gepuffter Amarant,
so ein Pseudogetreide,
aber hat auch ganz viele tolle Mineralstoffe.
Ein großer, guter Energielieferant.
Und ich finde die kleinen Kügelchen einfach megasüß.
Deswegen habe ich immer Amarant da.
Und wisst ihr was?
Jetzt einfach kurz mit der Hand noch mal durchkneten.
Und dann merkt ihr auch, ob die Masse klebrig genug ist,
damit sie hält.
[Musik]
I need dollars, dollars!
A dollar is what I need!
Hey, hey!
Mir schwirren jetzt lauter 90s-Songs im Kopf rum.
Aber okay, das war nicht 90s.
Okay.
Und jetzt habt ihr diese klebrige Masse.
Das macht auch echt Spaß, die zu kneten.
Also Samira hätte da auch viel Spaß dran.
Denn es fühlt sich so leicht an wie Slime.
Vor allem mit diesem Amarantkügelchen,
ist schon was für Kinder.
Also da dürft ihr die Kinder gerne miteinbeziehen.
Und jetzt ist das ja eine klebrige Masse.
Ihr könntet jetzt Kügelchen formen,
aber es klebt dann auch ein bisschen zwischen den Händen.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt Backoblaten
und packe die dazwischen.
Ich glaube, die hier mache ich
auf die drauf, so ein bisschen größer, 70 mm.
Backoblaten kennt man meist aus der Weihnachtszeit,
aus der Weihnachtsbäckerei,
für Makronen und für Plätzchen.
Aber die können einfach viel mehr als nur Weihnachten.
Und die gibt es in eckig und rund.
Und ich nehme jetzt...
Ja, ich nehme mal jetzt 70 mm.
Vegan sind sie auch.
Ich nehme jetzt den mittleren Eisportionierer.
So.
Dann habe ich immer die gleich große Portion.
Ich packe das da drauf.
Und dann einfach eine zweite Oblate drauf
und zusammendrücken.
Oh, ich weiß was.
Ich drücke es mit der Burgerpresse!
Dann wird es schön gleichmäßig.
Oh yes!
Oh, jetzt habe ich es zerdrückt.
Okay, etwas weniger Druck.
Aber das ist cool.
Ja, so mache ich das.
Weil dann kann man sie wirklich schön in die Hand nehmen,
hat keine klebrigen Finger
und kann sie toll aus der Hand essen,
ohne dass sie aneinander kleben.
Und ich finde die von der Größe her super.
Ja, so mache ich die jetzt.
Also Oblate.
[Musik]
So.
Zweite Oblate drauf.
Und erst mal ganz vorsichtig,
dass es sich verteilt
und damit es schön glatt wird.
[Musik]
Vielleicht muss ich dazusagen, dass man
die zweite Oblate wirklich mit leichtem Druck,
aber sehr gefühlvoll auf die erste drückt,
damit sie nicht bricht.
Jetzt habe ich eine übrig.
Also die Müslisnacks sind im Prinzip schon fertig.
Was ihr jetzt noch machen könnt
und was ich auch megasüß finde
– also die sind ungefähr zehn Tage im Kühlschrank haltbar.
Aber so lange halten die nicht,
also bei uns nicht.
So zwei Tage und dann sind die aufgefutt-
– ein Tag, dann sind sie aufgefuttert.
Was ihr jetzt echt noch machen könnt,
wenn ihr das für eure Kinder macht
oder für euren Partner oder für euch selbst oder für Freunde,
ihr könnt Lebensmittelfarbstifte nehmen
und was Süßes draufschreiben oder malen.
Gerade so für Kinder.
Ich glaube, für Ela wäre so ein Regenbogen ganz süß.
Und dann könnt ihr eurem Mann
oder eurer Frau was draufschreiben,
so was Schönes,
so: "Schatz, bring mal den Müll raus."
Nein.
So: "Schatz, ich liebe dich."
Guckt einmal.
Und das sind alles Lebensmittelstifte.
Mit denen könnt ihr auf Oblaten malen.
Ich glaube, Ela freut sich echt über einen Regenbogen.
Und dann ist es ja auch gleich mal attraktiver für Kinder.
So.
Okay, wahrscheinlich mache ich jetzt
die Regenbogenfarben wieder falsch
und dann schimpft jemand.
Tschung!
Okay, es gibt schönere Regenbogen.
Macht nichts.
Hier, guckt mal. Jetzt schreiben wir noch was Süßes drauf.
[Musik]
So. Und das war jetzt so Variante eins,
also eher so der fruchtige Müslisnack,
so ein bisschen leicht nach Orange,
schöne Früchte mit dabei.
Und jetzt mache ich noch eine Schokoversion,
aber ohne Schokolade.
Und dafür habe ich hier schon die Zutaten.
Ich nehme 100 Gramm Haselnüsse,
50 Gramm Erdnüsse,
– die sind gesalzen –
50 Gramm Cranberries,
50 Gramm Datteln,
20 Gramm Äpfel,
20 Gramm Amarant,
50 Gramm Erdnussbutter,
20 Gramm Kakao
und 20 Gramm Kakaonibs.
Und jetzt hier auch wieder das gleiche Spiel.
Erst mal die Nüsse und Früchte zerkleinern.
Und auch hier könnt ihr natürlich
einfach wieder die Zutaten austauschen,
die ihr nicht so gerne habt.
Cranberries wieder mit rein,
die Datteln und Äpfel.
Ich mache da auch immer ganz gerne Resteverwertung,
also, wenn ich noch offene Nüsse, Früchte habe,
einfach alles mit rein.
So.
Und auch hier gebe ich Amarant zum Schluss dazu.
Die Erdnussbutter
als Kleber.
Kakao dazu
für den Schokoladengeschmack
und Kakaonibs.
Und die sind wirklich super,
denn man hat den Schokoladengeschmack,
aber ganz ohne Zucker.
Kakaonibs ist ja so gebrochene Kakaobohne.
Und jetzt alles wieder schön verrühren
beziehungsweise ich werde es jetzt gleich wieder verkneten.
Aber ich sehe schon, ich brauche etwas mehr Erdnussbutter.
Oder mehr Früchte könnt ihr auch nehmen,
damit das einfach schön zusammenklebt.
Ich schreibe euch dann die korrigierte Menge einfach auf.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier noch mal ein bisschen Erdnussbutter rein
und noch mal Datteln.
Aber mir ist die Masse noch zu trocken.
Und dann ist mir eingefallen:
Ich habe Haferflocken vergessen.
Also werde ich doch noch kurz Haferflocken
und Orangensaft dazu geben.
Aber ich werde die Haferflocken
mit dem Orangensaft kurz zerkleinern.
Wenn ihr es nachmacht
– ich experimentiere jetzt gerade ein bisschen.
Wenn ihr es nachmacht,
dann macht ihr einfach alle Zutaten direkt in den Mixer
und dann kommt diese klebrige Masse auch dabei raus.
Aber ihr seht schon,
ich habe heute auch ein bisschen versucht,
meine Reste zu verwerten.
Und dann könnt ihr echt ein bisschen rumexperimentieren.
Hauptsache, die Masse wird klebrig,
damit sie formbar ist.
Also Haferflocken,
Orangensaft.
Ich gebe auch noch ein bisschen von der Masse dazu.
So.
Jetzt habe ich hier eine tolle Konsistenz.
Und damit lässt sich jetzt alles auch gut formen.
[Musik]
Und da müsst ihr jetzt einfach mal ausprobieren,
ob eure Kinder das so mögen.
Es ist halt weniger süß
als die Dinge, die sie vielleicht sonst kennen.
Aber ich muss auch echt dazu sagen,
man kann Kinder dazu erziehen,
dass sie einfach weniger süß gewohnt sind.
Meine Kinder zum Beispiel,
die haben von mir noch nie Fruchtzwerge gekriegt
oder so einen Fruchtjoghurt.
Wir machen das einfach selber.
Ich nehme einfach einen Joghurt, so Naturjoghurt,
ganz ohne Zucker,
schneide da Erdbeeren rein,
Äpfel rein, ein bisschen Zimt dazu
oder Pfirsiche.
Und die essen das dann als Fruchtjoghurt.
Und dann muss man echt diese ganzen süßen Joghurtsorten
aus dem Supermarkt gar nicht erst verfüttern.
Und die gewöhnen sich erst gar nicht
an den süßen Geschmack.
Die trinken auch einfach nur Wasser
oder mal verdünnten Saft mit Wasser.
Und ich finde, da muss man schon ein bisschen gucken,
dass man die Kinder weg von dem ganzen Zucker kriegt
oder halt erst gar nicht ranführt.
Die Ela zum Beispiel, die isst
– also die trinkt nur Wasser.
Klar, wenn sie irgendwo mal sieht,
dass jemand eine Fanta oder eine Cola hat,
– so was kriegt sie bei mir nicht.
Aber ich kann sie dann damit veräppeln,
dass ich dann sage, ein bisschen Orangensaft
und Sprudelwasser drauf ist halt Kinder-Fanta.
Und dann trinkt die das.
Ja.
Die Samira, die ist schon ein bisschen erwachsener.
Die kann man nicht mehr so leicht veräppeln.
Die probiert natürlich jetzt auch schon die Sachen aus.
Aber so bei den Kleinen kann man schon noch
ein bisschen tricksen und herumexperimentieren.
Okay.
Hier nehme ich jetzt die kleineren Backoblaten,
die 50 mm,
habe ich einfach eine andere Größe,
nehme jetzt auch den kleinen Eisportionierer.
Jetzt habe ich eine perfekte klebrige Masse.
Und genau das gleiche Spiel.
Was ihr aber auch machen könnt,
falls ihr sagt: "Nee, ich will das jetzt nicht so machen",
dann könnt ihr auch kleine Kugeln formen
und zum Beispiel in gemahlenen Nüssen wälzen.
Dann klebt es nicht mehr.
Aber ich finde, so habt ihr einfach eine schöne Form
und könnt sie auch wunderbar lagern im Kühlschrank,
schön gestapelt,
und habt auch wirklich ganz wenig Platzverbrauch.
Okay, Samira möchte den ersten probieren.
Also das ist eine Schokoschnitte.
Aber ganz ehrliche Meinung.
>> SAMIRA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ist gut?
Magst du mit zur Schule nehmen?
Kannst du auch mit deinen Freunden teilen.
>> SAMIRA: Ist da Nuss drin?
>> SALLY: Nüsse sind drin und Haferflocken,
also nichts für Mia und Jana,
aber alle anderen dürfen essen.
Gut?
Cool!
Also Samira ist begeistert.
Das freut mich.
[Musik]
Guckt mal.
Jetzt kann ich die hier einfach schön luftdicht verpacken
und im Kühlschrank lagern
und dann den Kindern oder dem Murat
einfach jeden Morgen mitgeben.
So.
Ela ist im Kindergarten,
Samira ist gerade drüben,
aber ein Kind habe ich trotzdem da
und das ist der Dennis.
Komm, Kevin!
>> DENNIS: So...
Och! Hey!
So wird man gerne nicht vorgestellt.
>> SALLY: Die sind sogar vegan!
Ach, komm. Wir sind doch alle ein bisschen Kind.
>> DENNIS: Ja, das stimmt.
>> SALLY: Guck mich an. Ich bin Kind der Neunziger heute.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Siehst du das?
>> SALLY: Hast du das erkannt so?
>> DENNIS: Sieht cool aus.
Hast du so Hippie-
– nee, nicht Hippie.
>> SALLY: Nee, so Neunziger halt.
>> DENNIS: Back to 90s.
>> SALLY: Ja, also
das sind so kleine Müslisnacks zum Mitnehmen,
>> DENNIS: Okay.
>> SALLY: für das Büro, zum Frühstücken,
mal für die Energie zwischendurch.
Hier so die großen, die sind so fruchtig
und die sind schokoladig.
Darfst du beide probieren.
>> DENNIS: Sieht lecker aus.
>> SALLY: Und da kann man so Botschaften draufschreiben.
>> DENNIS: Oh!
>> SALLY: Mit Lebensmittelfarbe.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
Das erinnert mich gerade an meine Mama.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> DENNIS: Ja, und ich früher, wo ich noch klein war,
in die Schule gegangen bin
>> SALLY: Finde ich voll schön,
wenn ich dich an deine Mama erinnere.
>> DENNIS: und ich Brot halt gemacht bekommen habe
und dann so ein Zettel drauf:
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: "Viel Erfolg bei der Mathearbeit" oder so.
>> SALLY: Siehst du!
>> DENNIS: Hat nicht geklappt, aber ja.
>> SALLY: Hier, guck: "Viel Erfolg!"
Wenn man weiß, das Kind schreibt eine Mathearbeit.
Bitte schön.
Viel Erfolg wünsche ich dir.
>> DENNIS: Dann bin ich ganz aufgeregt
und dann probiere ich.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Mmh! Riecht schon mal lecker.
>> SALLY: Wisst ihr, der Dennis, der kann nicht mehr
so viel probieren bei uns, weil er halt vegan geworden ist.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und?
>> DENNIS: Immer!
Sehr lecker!
>> SALLY: Juhu!
>> DENNIS: Jedes Mal, wenn ich bei dir probiere,
sage ich immer: "Mmh! Sehr lecker!"
Aber es ist halt so.
>> SALLY: Oh, das freut mich.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und vor allem ohne Zusatzzucker.
Weißt du? Einfach nur aus den Früchten heraus,
Nüsse dabei, ungesüßtes Kakaopulver.
>> DENNIS: Fein.
Und die?
>> SALLY: Was hättest du hier gerne?
>> DENNIS: Fruchtig.
Mh.
Ich nehme den Regenbogen,
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: weil das Wetter so schön ist draußen.
Hm.
>> SALLY: Oh! Ich glaube, für Ela mache ich dann
noch eins mit, wo draufsteht: "Für David".
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und dann kann sie es für ihren Freund mitnehmen,
für ihren Kindergartenfreund.
>> DENNIS: Hm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Voll süß!
>> DENNIS: Die haben ja gestern zusammen gespielt, nicht?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Baby haben sie gespielt.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Haben sie Mutter-Vater-Kind?
>> DENNIS: Hm. Ja.
>> SALLY: Oh, das habe ich auch immer gespielt.
Ich war schon im Kindergarten immer die Mutti,
habe immer alle versorgt,
>> DENNIS: Mmh!
>> SALLY: gekocht.
Gut?
>> DENNIS: Ich gehe dann mal hoch.
>> SALLY: Guck. Und dann kann man die
einfach so schön lagern
und dann dem Dennis mitgeben.
So.
Die könnt ihr auch wirklich auf Vorrat herstellen.
Wie gesagt, so zehn Tage im Kühlschrank haltbar.
Bitte schön.
>> DENNIS: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Das Rezept finde ihr auf sallys-blog.de
oder in unserer kostenlosen App.
Die könnt ihr euch runterladen
und das Rezept ganz einfach digital hochrechnen.
Das heißt, wenn ihr sagt:
"Mhm, die Menge, die reicht mir nicht aus",
rechnet es einfach hoch,
macht gleich die doppelte, dreifache, vierfache Menge.
Mache ich jetzt auch gleich noch mal.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> SALLY & DENNIS: Tschüss!
>> DENNIS: Danke!
>> SALLY: Bitte!
[Musik]